(percussive music)
- Hi, I'm Dil Passings, a
representative from your area.
I'm here to make all your
legislative dreams come true.
- Are you a constituent
looking for a representative?
(echo)
- Do you ever stay up all night
wishing someone would
just listen to your voice?
- Call us for some good,
legal, all American fun.
- [Narrator] Two O Two Two
Two Four Three One Two One.
Two O Two Two Two Four Three One Two One.
- You can tell us about any issue
that you deeply, deeply care about.
- [Narrator] Democracy.
- Marriage equality.
- Renewable energy.
- Immigration.
- Freedom of information.
- Reproductive rights.
- Affordable health care.
- And so much more.
- [Narrator] Two O Two Two
Two Four Three One Two One.
Call now.
- And guess what?
You don't have to be over 18 to call.
It's fun for the whole family.
- No matter where you live.
- Where you come from.
- Or what you believe
in, we're here to listen.
- There's nothing sexier
than active resistance.
Use your voice.
- We are the people.
- We have the power.
- We can make a difference.
- So call us now.
Seriously, it's not that hard.
- [Narrator] You know
what's better than sex?
Democracy.
- Hi, my name is Kevin.
I am not a senator, but I'm a member
of the great big disco dance
party known as America.
What you just saw was obviously a parody,
but the number presented
was absolutely real.
Call this number below,
and you'll be connected
to a switchboard where you can contact
your local member of Congress.
These people depend on you
and your vote for their job,
so they want to hear from you.
So if you're watching the news,
or just scrolling through
Facebook and seeing angry memes
and just feel angry or hopeless,
just remember that there's
something you can do about it,
and it's actually really easy.
Just punch in these ten beautiful digits,
and you'll be connected to
your specific Congressperson.
Tell them your hopes, your
opinions, and your worries.
Ask them how they're gonna
vote on particular bills.
Remember, they work for you, and trust me,
they're gonna write this all down.
It's their job.
If you want more information about
contacting your representative,
take a look in the video description
and call your representative today.
I'm gonna call mine right now.
It's real easy.
It's busy, but we're gonna keep trying.